abdullah ahmed abdullah era conocido por
su nombre de guerra como muhammad al
masri considerado el segundo hombre en
importancia a la organización al qaeda
que por muchos años fue quien se encargó
del entrenamiento de los milicianos y
fue uno de sus fundadores se le
considera uno de los terroristas más
buscados por eeuu especialmente por
estar vinculado con ese gran ataque o
doble ataque que sucedió en kenia y
tanzania en 1998 contra las embajadas
norteamericanas donde murieron 224
personas se cree según dicen fuentes
norteamericanas al diario the new york
times- estaba en custodia en irán del
del 2003 donde residía y en los últimos
años ya vivía casi en libertad en una de
las calles céntricas de teherán donde
habría sido asesinado el pasado 7 de
agosto por dos hombres que le dispararon
al coche con conducía cuando iba con su
hija en aquel momento se conoció la
muerte de otro hombre en ese momento lo
vincularon con la organización
conocido como javi debut pero ahora
resulta que según esta información
dawood era el nombre que se le daban
irán al masri aunque las autoridades
iraníes lo han negado hoy rotundamente y
dicen que esto es uno de esos escenarios
tipo hollywood que se crea eeuu para
vincular a irán en esa gran guerra que
tiene para desprestigiarlo